[Music]
hey everybody time once again for my
tomes of terror book review series
so
several weeks back maybe it was a month
i can't really remember exactly
i was contacted through email by an
independent author named christina
mirzoy i hope i'm pronouncing that right
if i'm not i apologize
uh but she contacted me and asked if i
would review her book the headsman
which actually came out
it was published in january of 2022 i
think and it was also available to read
for free on kindle unlimited which is
really good service and i use it a lot
for these book reviews
so i started doing a little bit of
background research into christina
mirzoy
and that led me to discover some kind of
like interesting things about her she's
actually a very new emerging writer
she's a young romanian woman
who actually speaks four languages but
mainly at least so far reads and writes
in english not only because i was
reading an interview with her and she
said that she finds it's what she calls
english's rich vocabulary um more
suitable to expressing herself like what
you know the stories she wants to write
but also she said because a lot of her
favorite authors such as ray bradbury um
are american or british so she read a
lot of that american or british like
fantasy like growing up
so she's very very influenced by dark
fantasy greek mythology
gothic literature
weird fiction
and fairy tales probably most
prominently all of those elements are
very very readily apparent in her book
the headsman
now the book only clocks in at a little
over 40 pages 41 pages 42 pages
somewhere around there but i have to say
that it actually really does pack a lot
of
this just really creepy like uncanny
kind of atmosphere and a lot of real
chilling like intrigue into a very small
space
and i will also say that this is
definitely a story you'll want to read
through a few times um to kind of catch
all the intricate details that are
interwoven in there
in form it's not really a novel
necessarily nor is it a short story it
reads something like a collection of
short stories but they're all
interrelated
and each story or chapter i guess if you
want to call it that is told from the
perspective of a different character so
the action takes place in true grimm's
fairy tale fashion
in some sort of quasi-mystical perhaps
medieval village
in no concrete time or place
the first story which is told from the
point of view of the headsman in other
words the village's executioner
is called the witch
and it describes sort of like the
headsman's infatuation with the
beautiful wife of the duke uh you know
of the village
and this headsman is eventually called
on to execute her after she is accused
of witchcraft
so from here on out each story kind of
fills in
more and more particulars about this
village and its people
and with each kind of like shift in
viewpoint and sometimes in time frame
because i think it does kind of like go
back in time sometimes as one of the
characters is like talking about
something that happened in their past
um you get kind of like further and
further drawn into this kind of
grim web of deceit and betrayal and kind
of like all these complicated things
going on like among all of the townsfolk
now none of the characters are ever
named they're only ever referred to by
their i guess their station in life
for example the flower girl
the young fool the merchant the big man
the duke the mother the maid
the servant boy and the martyr
there's also as far as i can recall no
dialogue uh everything is laid out in a
very matter-of-fact very elegant prose
much like as i mentioned a fairy tale or
like kind of sort of like an unsettling
legend or series of legends kind of told
around a campfire type of tone to it now
the pretty genius thing about the way
the book is presented
is that while each story or story
fragment whatever you want to call it is
quite beautiful and really evocative and
very magically spooky like all on its
own
each successive story actually builds on
the last one
so what you learned about
you know for example what you learned
about the woman selling flowers in the
first tale which was told from the
headsman's perspective the next one is
actually told from her perspective and
she goes back in time and tells a little
bit about that so everything you thought
you knew about her from the first story
that was from the husband's perspective
is sort of like upended and
re-contextualized
by the next story so it kind of goes on
like that where it's like things are set
up like one person's perspective is said
and then you kind of get come at it from
a different angle and like see it from
you know maybe the person who was the
victim in this or maybe like another
person that was involved that knows some
information that this person didn't know
and stuff like that
so you also learn for example again how
the duke's wife the supposed witch ended
up in her predicament like how she ended
up getting executed and all the other
kind of
subterfuge and knavery and all this kind
of stuff that's going on behind the
scenes of this
kind of i'm not gonna lie like this very
mean and like vindictive little village
and i will say too that despite the
book's brief run time uh i know that's
usually just made for movies but it
applies here as well the language that
she uses is so
concise and like so descriptive
that it kind of feels as though there's
just whole
oceans of implication and emotion and
stuff like going on behind the pages you
know what i mean it's it really is
evocative of a much larger world even
though it's like very very short um
almost kind of like a long form prose
poem i think like the the prose is very
straightforward it's not but it is very
like i said she's she's just very good
with language and of kind of implying
like a much larger world beyond the
words and not a single word in this goes
to waste um and if you're paying
attention and like i said this is
probably why you want to read it through
a few times i actually read it through a
couple times um for this review you will
start to notice like all this an entire
wealth of like little clues and reveals
and all these interlinked details
between the stories and kind of like
foreshadowing of later events that are
sort of like flitting around like behind
you know behind the lines of text in
there and it's just really really great
like the way everything is just so
intricately like locked together but a
lot of times you really have to kind of
like read it just to kind of appreciate
how like i said how
deeply connected like all of these
people's stories are and
a lot of stuff like i said is
implication like some things that you're
kind of like suggested in this story
like you don't really figure out how
that pans out until later on and then
you're like oh my gosh that goes back to
that story like that guy and everything
like that so that's like really really
cool now i realize that this review is a
little bit shorter than what i would
normally do
but the book itself is so short that i'm
kind of hesitant to say any more about
it because i think that if you're going
to come to this you should kind of
experience it for yourself without
really knowing because like i said i
don't really have any preconceptions i
actually didn't even know that it was
that short or that or that it was uh
constructed in that way so it was kind
of like a nice surprise see you know
even though i read it for the first time
in less than an hour uh you know because
like i said it's only about 40 pages
it's actually sort of lingered in my
mind since then uh almost like this kind
of creepy but still like alluring
nightmare that you can't shake you know
what i mean it's that kind of you know
it just kind of sticks with you in that
way just the whole
i don't know just the whole aesthetic
the whole mood of it i read an interview
with christina mirzoy in cemetery dance
and she actually stated that at the
moment she's working on another english
language fantasy novella
um based around a particular fairy tale
like a reimagining of a particular fairy
tale and i have to say that you know
just going by this i'm really excited to
see you know to to read more from her um
she has a very singular voice and she
has
you know a really like majestic command
of the english language and kind of
putting across a mood she's just really
really good at that and doing that in a
really spare you know way where she
doesn't need like a whole bunch of
flowery language because all of her
words
you know kind of suggest a lot of other
things you know what i mean she's just
almost like a poet in that way
um so i definitely think that she's
gonna be a person to watch in the dark
fiction sphere in uh many years to come
so if you have kindle unlimited like i
said it's very short it's only 40 pages
it'll probably take you could probably
read it in afternoon easily and it's
really if you're really into fairy tales
um or mythological type tales things
like that then you will probably really
dig this i just really liked the whole
the whole mood that it gave me the whole
vibe it's just really really good and i
would really like recommend checking it
out so as i said sorry this one's a
little bit short but you know that's
kind of the book was short and i didn't
really want to spoil a lot of the stuff
because a lot of the fun of this one i
think is discovering like all of the
connections between all the stories and
all the characters and i don't really
want to ruin that for anybody so that
will do it for this tomes of terror and
i will see you guys on the next one bye